♪
>>Sean: PRESIDENT BIDEN
RUSHING TO JUDGMENT CAMERO
DEMONIZING BORDER PATROL AGENTS
CLEARLY NOT KNOWING ALL THE
FACTS, THE BORDER PAGE EIGHT
AGENTS ARE FURIOUS.
ONCE AGAIN REPORTING FROM THE
BORDER IN DEL RIO, TEXAS.
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER SARAH
CORP CARTER IS WITH US.
SARAH, IT'S UNIVERSAL, EVERY
BORDER CONTROL CONTACT I HAVE,
EVERY MEMBER OF THE UNION I'VE
TALKED TO, THEY ARE APOPLECTIC
AND THEY ARE ANGRY, AND THEY
FEEL THEY HAVE BEEN UNFAIRLY
DEMONIZED, LIED ABOUT, AND THEY
WANT AN APOLOGY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE ISN'T A BORDER PATROL
AGENT OR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL IN DEL RIO WHO ISN'T
OUTRAGED BY THE PRESIDENT
STATEMENTS THAT THESE AGENTS
WILL PAY OR BY VICE PRESIDENT W
WHEN HARRIS STATEMENT COMPARING
WHAT HAPPENED HERE IN DEL RIO T
SLAVERY.
I AM HERE AT THE INTERNATIONAL
BRIDGE, THIS INTERNATIONAL
BRIDGE BORDER AREA IS RIGHT HER
WITH MEXICO AND HAS BEEN SHUT
DOWN FOR MORE THEN A WEEK.
THE COMMUNITY HAS BEEN FEELING
AT WHERE THEY'VE NOT ONLY BEEN
FEELING IT ECONOMICALLY, BUT
RIGHT NOW THE COMMUNITY AS
APOPLECTIC AS YOU SAID ABOUT HO
THE AGENTS HAVE BEEN TREATED.
WE WATCHED AS COMMUNITY MEMBERS
JUST REGULAR FOLKS CAME OVER
HERE TO THE BRIDGE TO BRING
WATER TO THE AGENTS, TO TALK TO
LAW-ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
THEY WERE BRINGING FOOD TO THEM.
I WANT YOU TO HEAR FROM A FORMER
, JUST RECENTLY RETIRED
MOUNTED POLICE BORDER PATROL
TRAINER, AND WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
HE HAD A LOT TO SAY TO PRESIDEN
BIDEN.
BIDEN HAD SAID THESE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS WILL PAY THE PRICE
.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING, THIS IS THE PRESIDENT?
>> IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO KNOW
THAT WE WORK FOR THEY ASK US TO
DO OUR JOB, AND WHEN WE DO IT T
THE BEST OF OUR ABILITIES, THEN
WE GET THIS KIND OF BACKLASH.
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S DANGEROUS
THAT THE MINISTRATION IS MAKING
THESE KIND OF COMMENTS TO
LAW-ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS?
>> OF COURSE.
THEY WEREN'T ASKED TO DO
ANYTHING OTHER THAN THEIR JOB.
THERE WAS NO IF I LOOK AT THE
VIDEOS IN THE PICTURES, THERE
WAS NO, THEY WEREN'T WHIPPING
THE HAITIANS AT ALL, IF ANYTHING
, THEY WERE USING THE
RAINS TO EITHER CREATE DISTANCE
FROM THE HAITIANS, SOME OF THEM
WERE GRABBING AT THE HORSE RAIN
AND THEY WERE EITHER USING THOS
TO KEEP THEM AWAY OR THEY WERE
USING THEM TO DRIVE THE HORSES
TO MOVE THEM OFF BECAUSE THEY
WERE RESISTING THE COMMANDS OF
THE AGENTS.
>> IT IS EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING
FOR MANY OF THE AGENTS.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS SITUATION.
THIS BORDER REGION IS FILLED
WITH MOUNTAINOUS TERRAIN, ROCKY
CONDITIONS FOR THE AREA IN WHIC
THEY APPREHENDED THE MIGRANTS
WAS ACTUALLY AN AREA WHERE THEY
NORMALLY PATROL, AT THAT AREA,
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET THEIR
BOATS THERE WHICH IS WHY THEY
WERE TRYING TO MOVE THE MIGRANTS
.
THEY SAY WHAT'S WORSE IS WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THE
ADMINISTRATION DID PUT A BIG
TARGET ON THEM BASICALLY GIVING
OTHERS THE RIGHT TO TARGET
LAW-ENFORCEMENT AND AT TIMES
THAT'S REALLY STRENUOUS FOR THEM
.
THEY GOT TO SAY THAT THEY WANT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO BAC
DOWN.
THEY WANT AN APOLOGY AND THEY
WANT IT RIGHT AWAY.
BY THE WAY, SO DO THE PEOPLE OF
DEL RI